d'abord je ne tiens pas du tout à me
passer d'une partie de la france quand
on est élu président on est évidemment
président de tous les français mais
avant il ya l'élection
et l'élection c'est un moment
démocratique
2-2
d'affrontement politique donc ce que
voulait dire l'affrontement politique ça
nécessite la discussion la querelle même
le clivage
avec des idées claires des idées net et
on s'affronte politiquement donc ce que
vous laissez à la démocratie c'est le
curseur un peu loin avant voilà pendant
votre campagne et si un jour s'ils
demandent d'être président vous allez
baisser le curseur il faudra essayer
d'être le président par les fondeurs non
c'est pas ça c'est pas ça ce que je dis
c'est que quand on est élu on est
forcément le président de tous les
français mais avant on n'est jamais élu
avec 100% bien sûr donc tout le monde
divisent en vérité oui mais vous met
donc attendez donc moi euh si vous
voulez je pense que la démocratie c'est
la meilleure manière d'accorder nos
différences nos désaccords nos
propositions n'ont conflit donc c'est ça
la démocratie
maintenant quand je choque des gens que
je que je les laisse délirante ça vous
fait non mais attendez vous attendez là
moi vous savez on ne me blesse aussi oui
je ne dis rien oui mais eric zemmour on
vous blesse parce que c'est par rapport
aux propos vous avez n'ont donc
forcément c'est un peu retour des choses
vous savez il faut pas non plus exagérer
moi je suis dans le verbe oui euh non
mais les menaces je ne suis pas levé les
menaces que vous recevez des ménages
mais je parlais pas de savent pas
d'accord ouais bah ça je ne tue personne
non mais tous je ne je ne tue je ne je
n'exécute pas un prof mais parce qu'il a
montré des caricatures mal à vous rendez
compte l' amalgame que vous faites le
compte n'y avait aucun amalgame je vous
réponds il ya plus de dix mots qui vous
me dites il ya des gens qui sont blessés
oui je vous dis moi je suis blessé tous
les jours par l'état de la france est ce
que dans vos équipes vous avez des
musulmans bien sûr alors il travaille
très bien et très bien ils sont heureux
d'être avec vous mais ils sont très
heureux d'être avec moi et ils pensent
comme moi moi vous savez je n'ai rien
contre les musulmans je pense que
l'islam est une religion totalitaire y
compris pour les mettant dans l'est
d'ailleurs tout à leur accueil et donc
je dis aux musulmans assimilés vous je
ne dis pas intégré vous l'intégration
s'est uniquement l'économique vous avez
un boulot vous respecter la loi ça c'est
l'intégration moi je dis pour être
français il faut reprendre le fil de
l'assimilation c'est la tradition
française et j'ajouterais même c'est la
tradition républicaine française
quand on dit de vous que vous êtes
raciste vous dit quoi que l'assimilation
est l'exact mais est-ce qu'on traite
baisse de ce que vous dites non ça me
dérange pas mais c'est idiot aujourd'hui
on vous êtes là nous tourner dans la
tête des gens vous êtes à la droite de
marine le pen
ça vous blesse il reste considéré comme
à la droite de marine le pen ou presque
je pense que je vais j'ai déjà répondu à
cette question mais je répondrai au
racisme apprécié monsieur amédée oui je
pense que je retrouve
vraiment la tradition politique golo
bonapartiste du rpr c'est ce que vous
dites souffrance je pense que ça vous
dirait que jacques chirac dit que
l'amiante non mais jacques chirac a
trahi vous dites déjà sur elle n'a rien
fait pendant ce n'est pas qu'il n'a rien
fait je dis qu'il a trahi sa famille
politique ouais c'est pas la même chose
j'ai écrit des langues là dessus il ya
longtemps le rpr garde caution du repère
c'est le rire eux sérieusement inquiétez
pas vous paierez je m'inquiète pas je
remercie mais parce que vous poser
plusieurs questions à l'effet d'analyser
rien de répondre à daisy pour le racisme
qu'est ce que le racisme et si on a une
minute le racisme c'est considéré qu' il
y à des races d'abord les scientifiques
aujourd'hui après avoir dit qu' il
existe des races aujourd'hui un siècle
plus tard les mêmes scientifiques disent
qu'il n'y a pas de race très bien et que
on distingue selon la race
une ont fait que chaque race est
différente et il y à une supériorité
d'une race par rapport à une autre parce
qu'on appartient à une certaine race est
sale raciste et ça veut dire qu'on ne
peut être franc c'est que si on est on
descend de clovis
moi je ne peux pas si vous voulez c'est
pas possible donc je considère
le problème je vais vous dire pourquoi
on me traite de raciste parce qu'il ya
eu une un dévoiement du terme de raciste
un raciste c'est celui qui mesure les
crânes 1 on est en 42
je ne fais pas ça aujourd'hui on traite
de raciste quelqu'un qui veut défendre
son identité son mode de vie sa
civilisation et ça ce n'est pas être
raciste c'est vouloir défendre
ça son pays et sa patrie et sa
civilisation contre des gens qui ne
veulent pas reconnaître qu'ils veulent
leur imposer une autre civilisation
d'autres meurent alors et d'autres modes
de vie je suis désolé ce n'est pas du
racisme
non